[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sure is
sure it's nice to leave our guns at home
and relax for a night oh yeah the only
thing better than being a cop is being
an off-duty cop speaking of which hey
bartender how about a cold brew
[Music]
ah just the way i like it
i gotta say this new nightclub's really
hopping it's wall-to-wall hipsters in
here yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
plus the vip rooms crawling with big
hollywood stars
look it's former california governor
arnold schwarzenegger
[Applause]
place looking making money hand over
fist
yeah and i think someone noticed
looks like this nightclub's being robbed
lock stock and justice will be back in a
minute but first a preview of the hot
new medical drama royalty free hospital
[Applause]
patience losing a lot of blood nurse
blevins hand me my scissors
[Music]
you better hurry doctor because it looks
like the hospital's being robbed
we now return you to lock stock and
justice
[Music]
[Applause]
the robber stole you sunglasses he stole
my sunglasses
good one partner i think we're
outnumbered look
yeah but we're not out gunned watch my
back okay
[Applause]
i got something to clear the dance floor
look out
you son of a [ __ ]
got the beer still i didn't want to
spill anything
he's getting away on his skateboard i'll
need to borrow your jeep and your rocket
launcher avenge me
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah just a flesh wound i'll drink to
that here's to never taking a day off
again
[Music]
[Applause]